c'est une défaite avec un goût amer pour
plaisir les jaunes et bleu se sont
inclinés 26 à 21 face à Courbevoie il y
avait la place pour les plaisirs
adversaire les hommes de Sébastien
ronali n'ont jamais réussi à franchir la
ligne dans les dernières minutes de la
rencontre pour arracher la victoire je
sais pas le nombre de fautes mais je
pense qu'il y en a bien une dizaine de
pénalités d'affilée à 5 mètres de la
ligne donc on verra tout ça la vidéo
mais bon c'est sur un cumul de fautes
comme ça je comprends même pas comment
il y a pas assez de tonalité comment il
y a pas plusieurs cartons bon enfin
vraiment voilà on est très très très
déçu effectivement par rapport à ça tout
avait pourtant bien commencé pour
plaisir après 20 minutes de jeu les
plaisirs amènent 14 à 3
Courbevoie recolle au score en
inscrivant un premier essai mais avant
le retour au vestiaire les aiguilles
noires reprennent le large à la mi-temps
plaisir prend de l'avance 21 à 13
revigorer avec plus de maîtrise
Courbevoie réussie son début de seconde
période en 20 minutes les visiteurs
virent en tête 21 à 26
le score restera inchangé jusqu'à la fin
de la rencontre peut-être qu'on se
trouve une fois ou deux défensivement
justement sur sur le début de cette
deuxième mi-temps ils reviennent dans le
match et du coup bon bah voilà ils sont
ils sont en confiance et nous après on
est obligé de courir courir sur le score
à la fin et voilà quoi c'est peut-être
en terme de la deuxième là qui est
regrettable avec son excellent début de
saison plaisir conserve la deuxième
place au classement malgré cette défaite
les plaisirs rois prennent un point de
bonus défensif prochain match prévu ce
dimanche 13 novembre à Domont